monsieur le ministre au moment de ma
dernière mon groupe que je salue m'a
fait l'honneur de me confier une
question qui fut au coeur de mon
engagement de mes plaidoiries de mes
travaux avec vous dans cette hémicycle
depuis de nombreuses années la
dépendance le plus réalise et la liberté
des médias je veux vous dire notre
inquiétude car on concentration
économique qui monopolise les médias
entre quelques groupes industriels et
financiers dont l'activité principale
est le plus souvent étrangère à la
presse à l'information ou à la culture
se construit devant nous un empire
médiatique de propagande au service
d'une idéologie qui promeule la haine de
l'autre
en effet Monsieur Bolloré qui est en son
empire à la télé à la radio à la presse
écrite au cinéma et à l'édition
qui en contrôle presque la totalité y
compris la majorité des livres scolaires
détruit des rédactions entières comme à
iTélé aura pas par image et maintenant
le JDD en lui imposant contre son avis
exprimé à 98% par les journalistes un
directeur renvoyé d'un journal d'extrême
droite parce qu'il était lui-même trop
d'extrême droite monsieur le ministre
vous ne pouvez pas nous dire qu'on ne
peut rien faire car la situation est
grave on peut mieux protéger
l'indépendance des rédactions en leur
permettant de valider à une majorité
qualifiée leur directeur proposé par
l'actionnaire et les états généraux de
la formation promis par le Président de
la République c'est pour quand
on veut répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué du renouveau
démocratique Monsieur Olivier Véran
un quotidien ou d'un autre journal le
vote pour désigner le rédacteur en chef
je sais que certains journaux le font
comme par exemple les échos moi j'ai
envie de vous dire Monsieur le Sénateur
il va y avoir d'abord il y a une
réflexion qui a commencé au Parlement
sous l'égide de la ministre de la
Culture dont j'excuse l'absence
d'ailleurs parce qu'elle est avec le
président de la République à Marseille
et les parlementaire ont aussi pour
objectif de regarder la loi blog 2016
pour voir ce qui pourrait être
éventuellement renforcé à mesurer ou
modifier dans ce cadre-là par ailleurs
vous l'avez dit vous même le président
de la République souhaite organiser des
états généraux de l'information qui
pourrait être pourquoi pas une
opportunité pour aborder ce type de
problématique il ne me revient pas de
vous dire que c'est précisément ce type
de problématique que nous aborderons
mais dès lors qu'on ouvre ce chantier
qui est important et bien on pourra se
poser toutes les questions qui qui
conviennent donc voilà monsieur le
sénateur j'espère avoir répondu non pas
sur le cas précis qui vous occupe et qui
vous mobilise mais sur le cas général de
l'indépendance du pluralisme et de la
liberté de la presse
tu as souligne
j'ai posé cette question sans esprit
polémique je pense qu'il faut un sursaut
j'en appelle à tous mes collègues sur
les bancs dans un monde où toutes les
démocraties sont menacées ou les
populismes centrés ont fait l'enjeu de
la liberté de la presse et vitale c'est
un enjeu républicain qui doit nous
rassembler c'est un enjeu démocratique
qui doit nous mobiliser je vous demande
de méditer cette phrase de Victor Hugo
la liberté de la presse à côté du
suffrage universel c'est la pensée de
tous éclairant le gouvernement de tous a
tenté à l'une c'est à tenter à l'autre
[Musique]